100 Titan theaters this weekend horror  fans will delight in this weekend's  offering the conjuring to a supernatural  thriller based on the true life case of  one of England's most notorious  hauntings the epic fantasy adventure  film Warcraft based on the popular video  game series brings the battle for  survival to the big screen  this weekend features the return of the  thrilling illusion filled caper now you  see me to the four horsemen reappearing  for a comeback performance to clear  their names  new faces Daniel Radcliffe and Lizzy  Caplan joined the magical mate and  finally let's find out what taught in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fan tissa patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  you